jungs weise zu trinken und wir schauen
auch nach kiel feierte vor ort unser
reporter paul ronzheimer wie immer paul
dass die russischen truppen sich für
eine offensive gegen den bon bars neu
aufstellen bedeutet also offenbar nicht
dass andere städte sich derweil in
sicherheit wiegen können
nein thomas vladimir putin der russische
diktator will offenbar ihr auch diesen
psychoterror die ständige angst der
menschen weiter befeuern indem er
raketen richtung lemberg schickt in dem
er hier auch in kiew raketen alarm
auslöst auch gestern sind wieder
menschen hier gestorben man hat das muss
man unseren zuschauern erklären zwar
durch den teilabzug diese ständige
gefahr der einkesselung gebannt aber was
man nicht gebannt hat thomas ist die
tatsache dass raketen immer das ganze
land treffen können das heißt nirgendwo
in der ukraine
nirgendwo sind die menschen wirklich
sicher deswegen wird auch vor einer
rückkehr zum beispiel hier nach kiew
gewarnt trotzdem hast du heute dort in
kiew am hellichten tag auf dem majdan
paul also auf diesen symbolträchtigen
platz in kiew mit den klitschko-brüdern
sprechen können
thomas das war eine ganz besondere
szenerie muss man sagen vielleicht auch
zur erklärung das ist ja der platz wo
alles begann 2014 die revolution damals
schon vitali klitschko der dort immer an
vorderster front war damals der
oppositionsführer gab spekulationen er
könnte sogar präsident werden und er
stand dort mit hunderttausenden die dann
dafür gesorgt haben dass janukowitsch am
ende geflohen ist und ich habe vitali
klitschko und wladimir klitschko heute
im bild interview gefragt wie fühlt sich
das an jetzt auf dem leiter einzustellen
für ein herz für unsere stadt für unser
land
alles was in
unserer stadt passiert dass leute kommen
zum ein herz doch dahinter steht eine
riesige schlange glaube ich paar tausend
leute stehen
ganzen tag nur eine marke kaufen marke
briefmarke briefmarke wo
steht der russische schiff geht weit weg
von buchrain das ist eine symbolische
briefmarke leute wollen das haben dass
es gibt
immer in hauptplatz passiert
etwas besonderes außergewöhnlich ist
dass seine symbolische platz bleib ich
mir wenn du von hier jetzt dorthin
schaust in den osten nach mario pohl
überall dort wo der schlimme krieg
herrscht was geht hier vor
kein schlimmer kriegen sondern
kriegsverbrechen
passiert wenn das land vor allem jetzt
in ruggell menschen haben kein wasser
kein
essen keine
möglichkeit aus dem keller raus zu
kommen weil die werden ständig
bombardiert
oder wenn hier aus sind dann können die
im kugelhagel sterben
es ist unglaublich was
in der eu politik gerade macht es ist
nicht mehr würden zu beschreiben es ist
eine pure kriegsverbrechen zerstörung
von existenz was passiert war den rippen
gleichzeitig hat man das gefühl
deutschland feiert ostern
versucht so ein bisschen abzuschalten
auf fast von dem was hier vorgeht und
immer noch sind keine schweren waffen in
der ukraine mit dem titel aus
deutschland zumindest
wir brauchen waffen wir brauchen nicht
nur bestätigen und beteiligungs waffen
verteidigen das wäre nicht nur unsere
stadt nicht nur unsere land und wurde in
deutschland um politik in deutschland
muss verstehen wir verteidigen auch
deutschland weil die sünde krieges sie
hinter krieges unsere wunsch ein teil
von europäische familie zu sein eine
demokratische land so aufzubauen und
jungs ab ganz andere vision die
sowjetische reich wieder auf zur warnung
deutschland muss deutsche muss niemals
vergessen weil von goisern ehemalige
dass er allein war ein teil von so
richtig rein wie geht ihr damit um dass
deutsche politiker weiterhin sagen keine
schweren waffen
das ist für immer war ein bisschen zu
spät das ist die jeden
tag wie jede stunde zählt am menschen
das
leben
und
das ist richtig dass es wichtig für uns
dass es richtig und so an dass es
wichtig für europa wieder früh wieder
frieden wieder
ruhige zeiten
zurückbringen
kann ich mir jetzt hast du in
deutschland viele gespräche geführt
genau über dieses thema waffen schwere
waffen jetzt sind ein paar wochen
vergangen und weiterhin sind keine
schweren waffen hier
ich werde mich noch dran wo ich wieder
an die konsequenz die versprochene
konsequenzen will chemie in den
versionen der ukraine macht
diese schien mit konsequenzen nehmen wir
mit unserem leben natürlich deutschland
unterstützt an und hat uns unterstützt
seit 2004 10 seit der revolution hier
und
jetzt diese kritische zeiten wo wirklich
es ist nicht mit fäusten des trans
verteidigen man braucht auch mittel und
braucht auch waffen um sie zu
verteidigen und frieden wieder dazu
stellen wir klar dass die noch nie da
sie und das ist immer ich sage mal
enttäuschend man will natürlich mehr
aber ich möchte das nicht einseitig
machen letztendlich deutschland versucht
ich möchte nie wieder deutschland nicht
im schutz zu nehmen oder gut reden und
das schönreden das gut erklärt
wir brauchen das wir brauchen das jetzt
glaube ich hoffe dass es wirklich kommt
und zwar nicht in wochentakt
stunde
wie erklärte dass vitali dass das in
europa so lange dauert präsident
selensky hat das ja auch scharf
kritisiert werden gleichzeitig in den
nächsten tagen die offensive im osten
noch größer werden kann also eine neue
offensive gegen städte und dörfer durch
ich bin fest überzeugt durch sagt komm
zur schaltung die schwere waffen zu
liefern aber das müssen wir beim ead
diese wartezeit wird mehr mittelmäßige
leben teilen das ist die durch die
politik
begreifen dass nachdem eine große
verluste und eine große gefahr für durch
reine oder hiob dass man muss schnell
entscheiden
das ist die bezahlung der trio die
wichtigste preis
wie wird es in der ukraine weiter gehen
aus deiner sicht wenn du auf den osten
schaust du gehst du davon aus dass die
großoffensive in der nächsten woche
startet
hat seine pläne und will seine pläne
trotzdem realisieren wo keine zu
kopieren die tief hauptstadt war ein
ziel und bleibt ein ziel und das ist
gegen russland nicht alle gesetze alle
alle werte alle menschlichen der einfach
verständnis was betrifft moderne welt
und wieder menschen zu sterben und die
zahl von menschen 1000 aus und wir
wissen nicht genau das ist zehn zwanzig
30.000 wie viel um wie viel durch eine
muss noch sterben bis zum eine bestimmte
zeit schwere waffen geliefert
gehst du davon aus dass auch kiew wieder
angegriffen werden könnte
wir kalkulieren verschiedene
sogar schlimmeres szenario
und die war ein zählung bleibt ein ziel
und
[Musik]
ich bin fest überzeugt sie sehen gesehen
wie virus und nennen sich
während geben sie keine richtige antwort
wenn zeigen wir 10
weiter wird uns angreifen kann ich mir
viele leute in deutschland fragen sich
ihr seid jetzt seit fast zwei monaten
hier seite an seite zusammen wie wie
geht es euch persönlich und wann kannst
du mal wieder nach deutschland zu deiner
familie dann könnt ihr dann kannst du
deine kinder wieder sehen
wie ist die situation wenn ich die
bilder im kopf wieder abrufen das was
ihr mutiges trieb ihn gesehen haben denn
man versteht wie sein kann und wie es
ist
das land ist ein teil von uns in diesem
dass das teil von von einem land muss
kann es nie gut gehen wenn in dem land
in unserem land in unsere heimat krieg
herrscht ausdauer ist angesagt ausdauer
also längst die luft nicht nur
emotionale sondern viele andere sachen
und deswegen bleiben wir so lange im
einsatz bis frieden wieder hier im lande
herrscht
und das wird kommen wissen nicht wann
das wird kommen und
bewegung stellen wir das komme aber
jeder krieg hat einen anfang und auch
ein ende ich hoffe nun dass es ende des
krieges schnelle kommt als langsam
vitali wie geht es dir damit dass du
deine kinder schon so lange nicht sehen
konnte dass es für dich auch unmöglich
ist sozusagen rauszukommen aus kiel
ich habe mich als ein team kabul
getroffen er kann nicht mehr in sein
leben seine eltern sehen weil er eltern
sind gedeutet
als relativ ums leben
wenn man schaut dann schreckliche wie
sehr was mit
zivilisten was ich nicht einfach
menschen die können nicht mehr
entspannen eine urlaub machen seine
kinder sehen weil die
sind dort schon
deswegen deswegen
jetzt leider kann ich denke die
vermisste
kinder familie aber dann wurde
und
ich hoffe die zeit wie möglich aber wir
müssen am menschen denken an unsere
stadt in euroland und alles vom wasser
trinken fonds machen schnell wie möglich
diese sinnlose krieg zu beenden und von
deutschen dass auch erkennt und deswegen
ich noch einmal bedanken sun alle war
zusammen mit rainer steht und an alle
von wem
wie sollten wir abhängt die waffen
schwer die lieferung schnell irgendwie
entscheiden am anfang des krieges in dem
interview hast du mir mal gesagt dass
dein sohn geschrieben hat per sms papa
pass auf dich auf als es so heftig war
etwas was sie jetzt was sagen deine
kinder genauso gleich die sind groß die
schreiben gerufen haben
[Musik]
beständig die die willkommene
information von allen acht filmen und
sie ist ziemlich
nervös sind auch viele was eine mögliche
atomare bedrohung angeht aus russland
präsident so lenski hat gesagt dass er
den einsatz von taktischen atomwaffen
für möglich hält seht ihr das auch so
nach die schreckliche bilder gott sei
dank
hier hingegen kommt sofort kamen
berichte waren völlig informationen was
passiert zum beispiel in boutiquen
variante gibt keine journalisten in
mariupol ivo ist ganz klar ganze stadt
zerstört und die hälfte von der stadt
und heike zerstörte genau das gleiche
schlimmere situation in die riege vor wo
gibt keine journalisten aber dort ist
eine richtige minister katastrophe
zivilisten sind gestorben was nach
solche schreckliche bilder
und bericht war und glaube
so weitergehen mit seine
kranke vision dass es im pda aufzubauen
hier der preis also hältst du den
einsatz von taktischen atomwaffen für
möglich ich hoffe ich nicht aber ich
schließe ich nicht aus lade mir wie ist
deine einschätzung
kann halt gedacht dass russland
jugendgerecht
genauso wie keine kann es fest sie davon
sichern dass die atomwaffen nicht
verwendet werden mann oder wir in der
ukraine rechnen mit allen an alles was
noch auf uns zukommen wird kann auch
schlimme folgen haben also wir rechnen
mit allem
sie rechne mit allem und paul du hast
die klitschkos dann auch noch zu den
bitteren streit befragte der zwischen
dem ehemaligen deutschen außenminister
sigmar gabriel und dem ukrainischen
botschafter in deutschland andré melnik
ausgebrochen ist und denen die beiden
gerade öffentlich über zeitungsartikel
und twitter botschaften austragen wir
erklären das noch mal kurz bevor wir die
antworten dann hören gabriel wirft
nämlich im spiegel verschwörungstheorien
vorbei der behaupte bundespräsident
frank walter steinmeier der gerade in
kiew nicht empfangen wurde habe in
seiner aktiven zeit als politiker seit
jahrzehnten ein spinnennetz der kontakte
mit russland geknüpft dazu schreibt
gabriel dann auf den punkt gebracht in
die nähe dieser vergleicht das der
frühere kanzleramtes und außenminister
die interessenvertretung russlands in
deutschland mit organisiert habe das ist
wahrheitswidrig und
bösartig der konter von melnik kommt
dann via twitter das schauen wir uns
auch noch mal an bösartig ist vor allem
ihre sigmar gabriel und ihrer spd
kumpane jahrelange putin freundliche
politik gewesen die diesen barbarischen
vernichtungskrieg gegen die ukrainischen
staat die ukrainische nation die
ukrainische kultur gegen ukrainische
frauen und kinder erst herbeigeführt hat
erst herbeigeführt hat die aufarbeitung
kommt noch shame on you also schämen sie
sich wir haben nochmal rein paul was
dann die klitschko brüder auf diese
vorwürfe gesagt haben während herzlicher
sowohl für die ukraine als auch für
deutschland schlecht
ich glaube dass herr melnik hat schon in
diesem austausch
genau gezeigt wird das alles heck und
ich meine damit gibt es auch einen
gewissen grund man kann darüber
diskutieren
aber fakten sie den fakten und von den
fakten kann man nicht irgendwie weg
laufen deswegen diese diskussion
zwischen gabriel und wenig es hat ein
gewissen grund und letztendlich diese
grund ist diese krieg was hier in der
ukraine herrscht aber es ist nicht
absurd dass dann gerade die spd den
ukrainischen botschafter zur jetzigen
zeit so anders
wir wissen dass ich möchte nicht tief in
die politik in deutschland gehen aber
letztendlich ist wird er immer war
unterstützend für diese freundliche
politik gegen russland und das wissen
der mit
vielen verschiedenen wegen und mitteln
inklusive geherrscht und es ist
letztendlich bekannt und liegt
tageslicht
ich
hoffe nur noch mal man wird nicht aktiv
in die politik gehen in deutschland
wichtig ist dass deutschland durch
unterstützt um sie mit einer front
gegenüber stehen dass diese krieg
beendet wird mit jedem mittel dass der
frieden wieder da in der ukraine
stattfinden wird wieder die du hast
viele spd-politiker auch kennengelernt
viele politiker verschiedener
koalitionen in den letzten jahren hat
deutschland ein putin problem hat die
spd ein putin problem war man zu
freundlich gegenüber russland
sollte so leide habe ziemlich oft
getroffen
bis heute ist heutige zeit so genannte
punkte und versteht es
wird
propaganda das wirkt dann sehr viele
russische medien was ist ziemlich lange
zeit in deutschland
gearbeitet und es gibt in
verschiedenen gründen aber leidet
problematik ist verstimmt gibt noch
wenn wir jetzt hier auf den platz
schauen da hinten sind noch ein paar
barrikaden aufgebaut man sieht sagt jack
point wann wird kiew wieder die stadt
die wir kennen aus der vergangenheit vor
dem krieg ist nur viel viel zu früh zu
sagen
zum normales leben kommen wir denke ich
mal in nächsten monate noch nicht weil
ist mir heute schon für das leben
gekommen ist
zwei briten von bevölkerung von gf
anwohner schon im tief
trotzdem ich hier
in chile an ihre bürger noch nicht zu
allen zurückzukommen weil heute gästen
waren griffen favorit also seine
kreativen stadt umgeht
vorgestern war ein tief eine luftangriff
angriff heute fünf menschen gestorben
deswegen die risiko ist noch da und gibt
es noch überhaupt sinnvoll und auch
draußen
langsam alles kommt in unsere stadt und
hoffen wir bald computing grund mit
frühling kommt auch friesen hoffen wir
vielen dank vitali klitschko vielen dank
ich mit klitschko alles gute und
hoffen wir alle dass der frieden schnell
kommt
ja mit frühling kommt auch wieder schön
wäre dass paul sag mir wie sehr belastet
dieser streit zwischen gabriel der ja in
der spd ist also in der aktuellen
kanzlerpartei und dem ukrainischen
botschafter in deutschland melnik das
deutsch ukrainische verhältnisse
generell im moment
ist zeigt erneut wie schwierig es ist
thomas wir haben ja in der letzten woche
diesen scharfen streit und wie von bild
enthüllte ausladung von frank walter
steinmeier lebt das hat natürlich dazu
geführt dass die diskussionen auch hier
in der ukraine wieder immens geworden
sind und immer wieder natürlich davon
betroffen das gemüse lenski unter
anderem immer wieder klar macht dass er
nicht zufrieden ist mit dem was
deutschland bislang geliefert hat und
das deutsche regierungspolitiker
insbesondere olaf scholz nicht bereits
in schwere waffen zu liefern also man
hat schon das gefühl hier in der ukraine
das insgesamt dieser streit tatsächlich
dafür sorgen kann dass die beziehung
dauerhaft belastet werden insbesondere
wenn jetzt im osten diese offensive
losgeht und russland dort erfolgreich
sein würde als die in kiew und dann wird
man natürlich erneut nach schuldigen
suchen und wird immer wieder sagen
deutschland hat nicht genug geliefert
auch wenn es vielleicht ein bisschen
unfair ist wenn man auf andere länder
wie frankreich oder italien schaut das
ist ja eher eine europäische ein
europäisches problem mit ausnahmen in
osteuropa aber deutschland ist hier zum
symbol des nicht helfen es geworden egal
wie fair oder unfair diese bewertung ist
und 20 uhr wird der ukrainische
botschafter andrej melik dann hier bei
uns in der sendung seinen vielen dank
nach kiew vielen dank an dich paul